If you're going to be an entrepreneur,
you almost have the opposite profile as
a soldier,
you're very high in openness and you're
lowering conscientiousness or at least
conscientiousness is irrelevant and the
reason for that seems to be that like if
you're an orderly person and you'd like
to follow procedures and rules,
it's kind of hard for you to start a
company because when you first start a
company or engage in any other creative
process,
because entrepreneurs turn out to be the
same as artists,
you kind of have to.
You're not operating within a rule
governed structure.
In fact,
there may be many times where you have
to break a small rule to move properly
at a higher level of analysis.
There is no algorithmic way of
generating a new company,
right?
Obviously,
and so it's people who are very high in
openness who happened to be good
entrepreneurs and so this is something I
thought was extraordinarily cool because
we'd.
We'd also already known what predicts
managerial,
administrative and academic ability and
Iq is crucial for any complex jobs.
So we'll just leave that behind.
But what predicts academic ability?
For example,
at the University of Toronto is
intelligence obviously,
but also conscientiousness,
the correlation between creativity and
grades at the UFT is zero zero.
Right?
But it's not.
It's not surprising that the thing is,
you know,
it's easy to be cynical about that,
but one of the things you have to
understand about creative people is that
they continually step outside of the
domain of evaluation structures.
Right?
Because if you're going to say you're
going to evaluate [inaudible]
performance of 100 professors on their
lecturing ability,
while you kind of have to measure what's
common across all the professors in
order to come up with the standards for
evaluation,
well that means you're not going to be
able to use that structure to evaluate a
particularly creative professor because
he or she is going to do something in a
way that's so different that it won't
show up on the evaluation measure.
And of course that's what happens in
universities.
You know,
somebody sent me a couple of days ago,
somebody sent me an essay that they had
written for their master's thesis that
was wildly creative and they were
basically told to leave the program and
that they couldn't continue.
Not in a mean way.
They.
What happened was that what they were
thinking was so outside of the
conventions in the discipline is that no
one had any idea what to do with the
essay.
So and then that's really the law of
creative people,
right?
They're always stepping outside of
evaluation structures and so it's not
that surprising that the relationship
between creativity and grades at the u
of t is zero.
We found out as well by looking at
graduate student performance across
multiple institutions that there was a
negative correlation between creativity
and graduate school performance.
It wasn't even zero.
It was worse than negative.
Being creative was negative and you
think,
well that could make you cynical as
well,
but.
But you can't be cynical in that way
because one of the things that happens
in science is that science tends to
progress incrementally rather than in
great leaps now.
And then someone comes who blows the
structure out of a science,
advances it ridiculously like Einstein,
but like most people aren't Einstein,
it may be,
thank God for that.
Most of the time you're in a discipline,
you,
you understand the discipline,
and then once you've developed
understanding of the discipline,
you know what the next micro question is
that should be answered and part of the
reason that science is so powerful is
because it allows people who aren't
genius level creatives to make real
advances in the generation of knowledge.
One tiny micro step at a time.
It doesn't matter if there's 100,000
people doing it and each of them is
making a micro step.
Man,
we're zipping along as fast as we
possibly wanted zip along.
And so it turns out to be
conscientiousness.
That's the excellent predictor of
graduate student performance.
That's the best predictor for law.
It's the best predictor for managerial
positions.
It's the best predictor for
administrative positions.
Anything that has a structure of rules
that needs to be applied,
conscientiousness is a great predictor.
So,
but it's not good for predicting
artistic ability or entrepreneurial
ability.
And that's also really important because
one of the things,
this is partly why bureaucracies
stultify right?
Because what happens is they,
as they develop,
they get chock full of conscientious
people with a few psychopaths thrown in
there just for good measure.
They get chocked full of conscientious
people busily zooming,
efficiently down to a single track,
and then all of a sudden the landscape
shifts and they're going very,
very efficiently in exactly the wrong
direction and then the whole bloody
thing falls apart.
So you need to have some creative wing
nuts in your organization to come up
with completely absurd ideas that might
just on the off chance be true.
And so creativity is strange in that
manner too because it's a high risk,
high return game.
You're a lot safer in your life to find
a functioning entity and to operate as a
cog within it,
as long as the entity keeps functioning.
Because if you're creative and you go
off on tangents all the time,
there's some probability that one of
those tangents is going to be exactly
what is needed at the time and you're
going to become hyper successful.
As a consequence,
but there's much more probability that
even though your,
some of your ideas might be highly
valuable,
the probability that this is the right
time and place for them is
extraordinarily low,
so to produce a successful creative
product,
for example,
in the marketplace,
you need a ridiculous combination of
creativity so that you keep generating
ideas and then a network around you of
people who have skills that you don't
and then the production of a of a
product,
let's say whatever that happens to be,
that's actually in demand by the
marketplace at exactly that moment and
that someone else hasn't already done
better.
So the sensible thing to tell anybody
who wants to be creative is that stupid.
You shouldn't do it.
It's,
it's your probability of success is so
low that it's better just to do
something sensible,
but the problem with that is that
creative people can't do that because
they're creative and if they shut down
their creativity,
it's like an extrovert who's gone to
live in a.
In an isolated cell,
a creative person who isn't being
creative.
They just.
They just wither and die,
so they're stuck with it.
So.
But it is a high risk,
high return strategy.